Okay, the way I like to go about auditing my
data is to write code that performs that kinds of checks
that I'm interested in doing. now, you could use something like
a piece of ETL software, there are a number. Clover, there
are some Python-based ones, PETL is one of those. For
me, I find those get in the way a lot and
this might just be personal preference. In terms of this class,
I think it's better for us to talk about the basics.
So what I'd like to do is just give you an idea for the type of process
in terms of the codes you'll be writing in
order to do auditing and cleaning tasks and we'll
just write Python scripts to do this. So in
my case, I'm interested in auditing the accuracy of
the country field here. So I've written a little
script here that is going to follow the process
I just described of comparing country field values in
our data with this reliable list of country names.
Now, this is the type of thing that we
would probably want to use a database for. So,
we're going to have a little bit of a
preview here for the next lesson in that,I'm actually
taking advantage of some data stored in mongoDB, in
fact, that country codes data, that I've stored in mongoDB.
And I'm going to just do a very
simple query in this code. That happens right here
using the PyMongo module. Which is the Python driver
or client library for Mongo DB. Again, what I'm
doing is moving through every value in my
cities data and executing a query against the database.
Asking weather the value I'm finding in the country
field is in that list of country names from
the ISO. Which I have stored in a collection in mongoDB. Okay
so, let's run this and see what we find. Okay,
so this just ran through all 20,000 odd cities and here's what we get as
country names. That were not found in our list.
You can see that in some cases what we've got
here is the need to do some further parsing
on the country field. Because we've got multiple names listed.
And you could imagine why for some cities,
there would be two names listed. So, let's just
note this. This is just problems with the country
field. So, the first thing that we found is
that some values are actually arrays. Take a look at this one. Or
this one. This is naming a county in Wisconsin, a county in
Texas and a county in Florida. So these are examples
of the wrong type of value being in the field. A lot of times that is due to
something called column shift which is a particular value
that got moved one column over. Now, that's probably
not in fact what happened here. But the idea
is the same. Someone entered a value that would
be valid in another field, other than our country
field. Then, we have some instances of data that
simply needs to be cleaned up a bit. So, the
parenthesis here is to distinguish the country of Georgia. From
the state by the same name in the United States.
And here you can see we've got an underscore separating
the individual words for this particular country. I would call
those examples of where we need regular expressions to come
to the rescue. We simply need to account for these
types of things in our field and clean them up by
writing a little regular expression That will pull out the
country name that's sitting there. And then finally, we've got
some countries that appear here that aren't recognized in our
list for one reason or another. There might be a political
reason. It might be a language issue. So for these,
we need to make a decision, and the decision is
whether or not we want to include these, maybe add
them to our gold standard list. That's something you really have
to make on a situation by situation basis. So, there, we
simply have possibly valid countries that we'll need to make a decision
about. Okay. So, this provides us with a nice concrete example
of how we might go about auditing accuracy for a particular field.